rachid mokhtari djamel mohamed et jérôme
se sont rencontrés à villeurbanne y a
deux ans depuis quelques mois ils ont
tout abandonné pour la musique
leur musique un rock mélodique qui parle
des immigrés et de leurs difficultés de
l'intolérance carte de séjour c'est le
nom qu'ils ont choisi pour leur groupe
avec humour
même s'ils sont préoccupés par tous les
drames qui secoue le monde musulman
ils puisent leur inspiration dans le
quotidien des banlieues
il ya des gens par exemple qui savent
pas ce que c'est l'immigration par
exemple des fois qu'on dit vol 1 ils ont
l'impression que ce sera mon bout du
monde alors que vos places à 10 minutes
de lyon
bon ça c'est ce côté là qu'on est qu'on
essaye de transposer et si on est un
lion et puis dans un peu dans toute la
france surtout pour ça
on n'était pas l'échiné en france quand
on peut être des déserts landais chez
eux en angleterre comme un peu partout
entre en agneau en ressemble au noir qui
sont aux etats unis ensemble mots aussi
bien aussi qu'ils sont en train de
singer âprement dollar leurs impressions
et puis ils vont au nicaragua et ainsi
de suite
bon ça les problèmes bon ah ah ah bien
sûr mais les problèmes internationaux
parce que bon à limiter l'immigration
c'est quand même une un peuple et
l'immigration c'est le peuple plus le
convoyage le plus puissant parce que bon
pour les appliquant des états unis s'est
quand même laissé les émigrés qui lis un
pays d'immigrés
après un premier 33 tours carte de
séjour partir en tournée pour 40
concerts en octobre à travers la france
une occasion supplémentaire pour ces
cinq musiciens de lutter pour leur
différence c'est pour cela qu'ils font
du rock par exemple vous êtes là
aujourd'hui si on n'avait pas fait de
musique si j'étais moi ma sao luis do
they soudeur je pense pas que vous irez
le voir